What it do, blood?
This yo boy, Sparky Sweets, PhD,
and this week, we gettin freak nasty wit "Fifty Shades of Grey" by E. L. James.
Pasty white girl, Anastasia, always doggin herself, thinkin she ain’t got da swagger to make boys holla.
But all dat change when she meets Christian Grey — a rich playboy who got foreign whips, helicopters,
kinky-ass fetishes, and a freakin sex dungeon.
You heard me — sex dungeon!
Grey don’t wanna jus tap dat ass, he wanna own dat ass — BDSM style.
Brotha even throw a contract in Ana’s face dat's gonna make her his legit sex toy.
But in da end, girl start realizin dat
she got da power, not only in bed, but in her life too.
Know what I’m sayin?
Fo those of you who seen my Youtube
channel, you know I’m usually playin da classic lit game.
But dis book right here got my mind spinnin.
How has it sold so many copies?
Sho, da book ain’t without its smart sh*t.
Like peep dis symbol, homeboy — when Ana up in Grey’s office,
she sees a bunch of regular-ass objects painted in a way dat make em look next level —
foreshadowin da change Ana gonna make from basic b*tch, to a confident, independent woman.
Or later when Ana drop in at da sex
dungeon, she talk about it lookin like a red “womb" —
which is straight up symbolic
of Ana’s rebirth into a mo complete person, ya feel me?
But as literary as E. L. keepin it, dat can’t be why everybody so geeked bout dis book.
Here’s what I think: we livin in a world where bidnesses get so damn powerful, dat even da law can’t touch em;
where yo skin color can be the difference between an opportunity and a bullet;
where society want nothin more than put you in a box and define you.
So maybe people love Fifty Shades, cuz like Ana, we feelin trapped in a world where we ain’t got no control.
And what’s sexier than seein her nut up, get dat power, and find some self-respect?
Or maybe people just like dicks and titties.
I hope yo b*tchass learned somethin today.
Peace.